of the Atelier Robin Rive machine, when should I do the 11th harmonic frequencies you gave me?
What are they for? So the 11th harmonic frequencies are really for kill programs. So
if you're running a viral program, if you set it at the 11th harmonic, it will run the frequency
plus the 11th harmonic, which is 11 times that frequency. There's been data that show that when
you run 11 times the frequency, which is called the 11th harmonic, with programs meant to kill
cancer or kill bacteria or kill pathogens of any kind, you'll have a much higher kill rate.
So that's another reason why I like the Atelier Robin is that you can run the 11th harmonic and
you can't do that with the true right. So when do you run that? Well, with people that have
the Atelier Robin, I write your program. You'll see a folder with your AA, your name, and then
ARR, that's just your normal cancer program. And then you'll see AA, your name, 11th. That's your
program in the 11th harmonic. The reason why I give you two folders is because I don't know if you'll get,
I mean, you could effectively kill too quickly. And we've seen this with the true right
with people with Lyme disease. If you run a Lyme program, you could kill that bacteria.
But you could by killing a bacteria, especially a gram negative bacteria, too quickly, you will
produce a lot of what are called endotoxins. So an endotoxid is the end result of that cell death.
When it's a gram negative bacteria, you're going to produce a lot of waste. And with a
gram negative bacteria, they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membrane. And that can be
overwhelming and difficult to detoxify. So if you produce too many lipopolysaccharides
from gram negative bacteria, that could be unhealthy because that could damage your blood brain barrier.
So we always, you know, we don't have any Lyme patients on this call because this is cancer call.
But would we program for a true rife or a telly or robin, which I haven't done yet for a Lyme patient?
But for the true rife, when we programmed for a Lyme patient, I would have very short kill programs
where we start off at only 15 minutes a day and go up to 30 and 60 and then a couple of hours
that have run overnight program. Because if you kill too quickly, you'll listen a lot of endotoxins.
Well, we don't know what's going to happen with cancer patients with the 11th harmonic.
Because this is the first time a machine has allowed you to do that. No other machine of the
market allows you to do that. So when we write the cancer program with the 11th harmonic, if it kills too
quickly, you might feel yucky the next day. And I don't want you just to feel yucky all the time.
So you might want to alternate the 11th harmonic program with your a your day, a rr program,
you know, every other night. I mean, if you do it and you don't feel, I don't feel like I want this
to kill my cancer and I feel fine. I'm not feeling like my, like I feel fluid. You're ready. You'd
get like a herximer type reaction where you'd feel kind of yucky than a headache, baby,
flu-ish. We don't want to go too quickly. So then we wouldn't do that. Now I also created the 11th
harmonic frequencies for the most common pathogens. So I created programs with the 11th harmonic
for the most common pathogens like the 11th harmonic viral program. With the true right,
if you got a viral complex program, it works great. While it's going to work a lot better,
when you run it with the 11th harmonic, now again, you can't do that with the true right, but you can
with your tillio-rabbit. So people that have the tillio-rabbit that have a folder with the 11th harmonic
kill pathogen kill programs that they can run for if they feel like a cold coming out or strep or some,
it's got a bunch of pathogens. A pathogen is a bacteria, fungus, a mold, a virus.
So you can run those at any time. If you feel like something's coming out of that COVID or
something like that, you can run the 11th harmonic COVID program. But for your cancer program,
you could start running those and if you have no ill effect of them, then you could keep running
just that folder of your weekly set. And you may never do the AA your name ARR set because you feel
fine doing the 11th harmonic set, which I think is going to be superior. But if you feel ill doing
that, then switch back to the other set. And if that was all very confusing, then just schedule a call
with me and I'll try to explain it. Maybe I'll create a video about that. All right.